[Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zur Sallys Welt.
Heute gibt es 3 Cocktails, die ballern.
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Sowas gibt es bei Malwanne und Kelly Misses Vlog.
Liebe Grüße an euch zwei.
Ich mache natürlich familienfreundliche, kinderfreundliche Getränke
für den Sommer, nämlich 3 Getränke ohne zusätzlichen weißen Industriezucker;
Getränke, die man einfach den Tag über gut verzehren kann.
Vor allem sollte man auch jetzt gerade an den warmen Tagen viel trinken
und ich muss mich selber immer dazu zwingen, viel Wasser zu trinken.
Ich bin so ein Wassertrinker. Wir haben auch eine BPT-Anlage im Haus
Das heißt, ich trink einfach den ganzen Tag Leitungswasser,
aber irgendwann wird mir das dann auch, wie soll ich sagen,
zu viel, zu langweilig und ich brauche auch einmal etwas mit Geschmack.
Ich bin nicht der Typ, der dann schnell Limonade greift
Ich bin eher so der Typ:
Ich nehme dann Zitrone mit ins Wasser oder mal so ein Rosmarinstängel.
Ich versuche mich da relativ zuckerfrei zu ernähren,
weil wir den Tag über viel mit Zucker essen.
Ich finde, bei Getränken muss es nicht sein.
Da reicht mir wirklich die Fruchtsüße.
Deswegen, habe ich mir überlegt, machen wir jetzt
als erstes eine Wassermelonenlimonade.
Wassermelone hat von sich aus schon viel Zucker
und ist schon süß genug;
ist ein toller Geschmack, den man da erzeugen kann.
Ich nehme dafür diese Wassermelone, eine Limette, Himbeereessig
und dann brauche ich noch zwei Zutaten.
Diese finde ich draußen im Garten, nämlich Himbeeren und Minze.
Da gehen wir kurz in Garten.
[Musik]
Es ist so witzig, denn die Minze hab ich hier eingesetzt.
Jetzt kann ich sie da vorne bei mir auch ernten.
Die ist nämlich bis dahin gewachsen. [Lacht]
Minze ist ein Phänomen; ist wie Unkraut, aber ich liebe sie.
Deswegen habe ich sie eingesetzt - egal!
[Musik]
Macht dann 3,50 €, bitte.
Dann kann ich jetzt hier die Wassermelone nehmen.
Die war jetzt auch schon im Kühlschrank. Also ist sie schön kalt.
Das ist auch eine mit wenig Kernen.
Teste ich es? [Zustimmung aus dem Hintergrund] Oder? No risk no fun!
Vielleicht haben sie es auch anders gemacht.
Vielleicht stelle ich es auch rein. Ihr könnt es auch auslöffeln,
aber so macht es mehr Spaß.
Ich habe es vielleicht auf TikTok gesehen. [Lacht]
Natürlich eine seriöse Quelle,
aber hey, funktioniert.
Also wichtig ist, man sollte die Wassermelone vorher abwaschen.
Das habe ich auch gemacht, damit die Schale außen auch sauber ist.
Hallo? Geht doch!
Vielleicht kann man auch den Whacker nehmen.
Also einfach das Wassermelonenfleisch zerkleinern und aushöhlen.
Geht bestimmt auch mit einem Löffel.
[Musik]
Den Rest kratze ich gleich noch aus,
aber mit dem lässt es sich echt gut zerkleinern.
[Musik]
Also der Grund, warum ich das Ganze nicht püriert habe,
sind natürlich die Kerne. Wenn ihr eine Wassermelone ohne Kerne habt,
könnt ihr einfach einen Pürierstaab nehmen.
Ich möchte aber die schwarzen Kerne nicht zerkleinern,
sondern möchte einfach heraus sieben sozusagen.
Die will ich nicht in der Limonade.
Ich nehme jetzt hier einfach die Flotte Lotte,
ihr könnt aber auch ein Sieb nehmen und das Ganze durchstreichen.
Wenn ihr aber sagt, die Kerne stören euch gar nicht,
dann lasst sie einfach drin.
Aber wenn man das Getränk mit einem Strohhalm trinken will,
dann ist es ein bisschen schwierig.
Also mich würde es nicht stören.
Deswegen zeige ich trotzdem, wie man sie entfernen kann,
aber mich persönlich würde das nicht stören. Dich, Josh? [Josh verneint]
Ich bin auch kein Mensch, der glaubt,
dass, wenn man Wassermelonenkerne schluckt, [Thriller Musik]
die im Bauch bleiben und eine Wassermelone wächst.
Habe ich schon gehört; sogar von einem Arzt - der Ali glaubt daran.
Als Kind haben das seine Eltern gesagt.
[Musik]
Also den Rest hier werde ich einfach löffeln.
Es hat trotzdem noch genug Geschmack dabei.
Und das hier wird jetzt die Limonade.
Hier gebe ich jetzt für den Geschmack noch Limette dazu
Wir haben gerade mit dem Josh besprochen:
Aus dem Rest machen wir ein Slushy Eis
einfach Einfrieren in einem Emaille Teller, da geht es recht schnell.
Dann kann man das als Slushy Eis löffeln.
Ich mache ein bisschen Limette darauf.
Limettensaft ist drin.
Bei mir kommt jetzt, wie gesagt, noch Minze dazu.
Im Prinzip könnt ihr dann diese Mischung in den Kühlschrank stellen
und einfach durchziehen lassen, was ich jetzt gleich machen werde.
Einfach noch Himbeeressig für den Geschmack dazu.
Da kommt ein bisschen Säure und Fruchtsüße mit rein.
Entweder könnt ihr das jetzt im Kühlschrank
einfach ziehen lassen für ein paar Stunden.
Was ich jetzt auch machen werde:
Ich mag nämlich die Limonade mit Soda spritzig.
Ich hab hier einfach eine Easy Flasche, mit der ich Soda machen kann.
Also einfach ein Soda Maker.
Da ist der Vorteil, dass, wenn ich jetzt hier die Masse einfülle
und dann eben mit den Soda Chargers aktiviere,
dann geht der Geschmack der Minze und Limette
direkt in die Wassermelone rein und ich muss nicht ziehen lassen.
Also im Prinzip so wie in Vakuumierer,
den ich auch oft benutze - die Vakuumschublade.
Da zieht auch sofort das Aroma z.B.
ins Fleisch oder ins Obst und Gemüse ein.
Hier ist es genau so: Dann kann ich gleich die
Limonade servieren ohne zu warten.
Jetzt muss ich sie nur noch einfüllen.
[Musik]
Wichtig beim Reinfüllen: schön sieben,
damit die Fruchtstückchen entfernt werden
und die Düsen nicht verstopfen.
[Musik]
Jetzt halb halb mit Wasser auffüllen, damit es nicht zu süß wird.
Hier gebe ich auch nur zwei Minzblätter rein.
Jetzt sind die Männer auch da und dürfen gleich die Limonade probieren.
[Musik]
Hier gebe ich jetzt Himbeeren dazu.
und Minze und Limette zur Deko.
[Musik]
Murat, wollt ihr probieren?
Sparkling Watermelon Limonade.
[Musik]
Hat aber echt eine geile Farbe. Bitte schön.
MURAT: Du hättest gern noch ein bisschen Gin drin, gell?
SALLY: Ah ja, könnt ihr machen.
MURAT: Natürlich hättest du jetzt gern Gin drin.
SALLY: Gin rein, Wodka rein...
MURAT: Wow.
SALLY: Wie schmeckt's? Darf ich bei dir probieren?
Wir sind ein Haushalt.
MURAT: Schmeckt wie BRA Eistee, nur viel besser.
DENNIS: Capital Brrrra.
MURAT: [Lacht] Aber echt cool, gell? [Dennis stimmt zu]
SALLY: Schmeckt echt gut.
MURAT: Richtig genial. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Wir machen 3 Getränke ohne zugesetzten Zucker, nur aus Fruchtsüße.
DENNIS: Nur noch Eiswürfel rein.
SALLY: Ja, Eiswürfel. Ah, ich hab die Eiswürfel vergessen.
I'm sorry.
DENNIS: Kein Problem. Schmeckt trotzdem.
SALLY: Ihr wart die Vorkoster. Jetzt können wir das Rezept wirklich machen.
Gut? Okay, ich mache noch zwei.
Dann rufe ich euch.
MURAT: Hammer!
Einmal die große Flasche bitte.
SALLY: Und die Himbeeren waren aus dem Garten.
MURAT: Ja, cool!
SALLY: Schön.
MURAT: Machst du uns nochmal eins?
SALLY: Ich mache euch...
MURAT: Für den Dennis einen, der ballert. [Sally lacht]
[Musik]
SALLY: Das zweite Getränk wird ein Mango-Maracuja-Eistee.
Dafür nehme ich als Basis grünen Tee.
Ihr könnt auch Schwarztee nehmen
oder auch einen ganz anderen Tee - was ihr gerne mögt.
Ich habe jetzt einfach so einen losen grünen Tee.
Ihr könnt aber auch einen Beuteltee verwenden.
Davon brauche ich etwa 1 Liter,
1 reife Mango, 4 reife Maracujas, Eiswürfel, Basilikum und Zitrone.
Ich habe jetzt hier mein Wasser schon aufkochen
und ein bisschen abkühlen lassen.
Grüner Tee sollte nämlich nicht
mit kochend heißem Wasser übergossen werden.
Ich brauche jetzt 2 TL pro Liter,
also wirklich nur ganz wenig.
Ich mache das jetzt so: Damit das Ganze schneller abkühlt,
gieße ich jetzt hier nicht 1 Liter heißes Wasser darauf,
sondern einfach ungefähr 200-250 ml,
lass es kurz durchziehen
und werde es dann mit den Eiswürfeln einfach kalt bekommen.
Ganz einfach!
In der Zwischenzeit kümmere ich mich schon einmal um die Mango.
Die kann ich nämlich hier rechts und links vom Stein - schaut -
einfach aufschneiden. Sie sollte wirklich schön reif und weich sein.
Jetzt könnt ihr sie hier im Glas ansetzen und - zack! - schälen.
[Musik]
Die Mango wird dann noch schön püriert.
Jetzt kann ich hier schon einmal ein paar Eiswürfel reingeben,
denn der Tee ist jetzt fertig.
[Musik]
Jetzt einfach auf 1 Liter auffüllen.
Dann kommt hier das Mangopüree rein.
Das wird jetzt auch noch einmal gesiebt,
damit da einfach zur Sicherheit keine Stückchen mehr sind.
Den Behälter wasche ich kurz aus.
Ich fühl mich grad wie in so einer Versuchswerkstatt,
mit diesen ganzen Behältern.
[Musik]
So. Dann auf jeden Fall die Basilikumblätter noch mit rein
Ich hatte das ja schon einmal erklärt:
Wenn man bei Minze, Kräutern und Basilikum usw.
die Blätter in die Hand nimmt und drauf klatscht,
entfalten sich die ätherischen Öle besser.
Dann kommt der Geschmack besser durch und ich brauche nur eine Karaffe.
Die hole ich noch ganz kurz.
Dann kommen noch die Maracujas und der Zitronensaft rein
und dann ist es fertig.
[Musik]
Bei der Maracuja einfach hier dieses Fleisch raus löffeln
und mit dazu geben.
Da mag ich die Kerne ganz gerne.
Deswegen lassen wir die jetzt auf jeden Fall drin.
Die sollten auf jeden Fall außen so richtig runzlig sein.
Dann sind sie schön reif und wenn ihr die Limonade dann trinkt,
auf jeden Fall auf die Kerne beißen,
weil die echt so einen richtig tollen Geschmack haben.
Die finde ich wahnsinnig.
Ich kenne viele, die sie dann weg sieben und aussortieren,
aber die sind echt schon richtig lecker.
Gerade mit Joghurt z.B. - sind schon gut.
Wie so ein natürlicher Bubble Tee, wo man einfach so drauf beißt
und es explodiert so im Mund.
[Musik]
Dann ist mein zweites Getränk jetzt auch fertig
und ich würde sagen, ich lass dieses Getränk Benny probieren,
denn Benny hat mir den grünen Tee gesponsert.
[Sally jubelt und klatscht]
Der Sponsor des heutigen Tages.
[Beide lachen]
Ich hatte eigentlich eben so ein richtig schönes Sektglas,
aber dann dachte ich mir, es ist vielleicht nicht männlich genug.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt einen großen Kelch. [Beide lachen]
BENNY: Was hast du da jetzt drin?
SALLY: Maracuja, Mango, Limonade...
Nein, eigentlich nicht; eigentlich ein Eistee.
Ist es Limonade, wenn es praktisch blubbrig ist?
Aber es gibt jetzt auch Sparkling Eistee.
But this is not Sparkling.
Was ist das?
Eistee oder? Auf grünen Tee mit Eis - ist doch ein Eistee mit Basilikum.
Man müsste es noch ein bisschen ziehen lassen, damit der Basilikum...
oder man nimmt so eine Easy Flasche.
Probiere einmal!
SALLY: Sauerstoff.
BENNY: Sehr erfrischend, sehr lecker.
SALLY: Ich finde es gut. Fehlt dir Zucker?
BENNY: Nein, es ist, glaube ich, gerade ganz gut für den Sommer,
wenn wir wenig Zucker haben, weil sonst trinkt man noch mehr. Sehr geil!
SALLY: Meine Worte. Ich bin ja auch dafür, dass wir Getränke zubereiten,
die einfach ohne zugesetzten Zucker auskommen.
Ich finde auch, die Süße aus der Mango passt.
Die sind krass, wie sie herausschmecken.
BENNY: Ich schmecke eigentlich auch...
Also ich meine, Mango und Maracuja harmoniert sowieso. [Sally stimmt zu]
Ich schmecke jetzt auch mehr Maracuja heraus.
Ja, finde ich super - kann so bleiben!
SALLY: Also wenn man möchte, dass der Basilikum noch mehr herausschmeckt,
einfach ein bisschen im Kühlschrank ziehen lassen
und dann kommt er auch besser durch.
So mache ich das jetzt noch perfekt.
Dann gibt's jetzt noch Getränk Nummer 3.
Dafür gehen wir nochmal im Garten, denn ich brauche Lavendel.
[Musik]
Das hier wird jetzt im Prinzip eine aromatisierte Apfelschorle.
Ihr könnt aber auch statt Apfelsaft natürlich
auch wieder am Tee aufbrühen oder einen anderen Saft nehmen.
Aber wir haben hier den Apfelsaft, den wir sozusagen gerettet haben.
Wir hatten nämlich von der Firma Stiefkind
die ganzen Apfelsaftflaschen gekauft,
weil der praktisch kurz vor dem Ablauf des MHD war.
Die Gastronomie hat ja nichts mehr abgekauft.
Dann haben wir ihn gerettet und an Kindergärten, Schulen
und soziale Einrichtungen verteilt.
War echt schön, muss ich sagen.
Ein paar Flaschen haben wir noch hier in der Firma.
Das jetzt mit Sprudel aufgießen.
Regionales Wasser vom Kevin und da kommt jetzt mein Lavendel rein.
Ich muss sagen: Wenn ihr möchtet, dass der Lavendel viel Geschmack abgibt,
dann könnt ihr den Lavendel ein bisschen mit dem Apfelsaft einkochen.
Ich glaube, das mache ich tatsächlich auch,
damit einfach nur ein bisschen mehr Lavendelgeschmack kommt,
aber ein paar gebe ich hier auch zur Deko rein.
Den Rosmarin auch einfach so ein bisschen verschreiben.
Weil ich mag den Lavendelgeschmack ganz gern.
Rosmaringeschmack auch, aber bei dem wäre es jetzt zu intensiv.
Das gebe ich jetzt hier so rein.
Wie gesagt, ein paar gebe ich einen kleinen Topf.
Ein bisschen Apfelsaft - muss es gar nicht so viel sein.
Dann Lavendel dazu
und wirklich nur bei ganz wenig Hitze ganz kurz erwärmen,
dass es wie ein Tee einfach ein bisschen ziehen kann.
Schon ein schöner Farbverlauf.
Yes!
Ach ja, die schöne Optik zerstöre ich nicht.
Ich mache ein Gläschen nochmal separat zum Probieren, ok?
[Musik]
Es ist jetzt hier schön durchgezogen.
Das kommt jetzt hier auch praktisch mit rein.
Ich serviere jetzt hier eine Portion so.
Ich glaube, das darf dann Sarah probieren.
Sarah liebt ja Blumen und Lavendel und Kräuter und Rosmarin.
Schön mit dem Farbverlauf!
Sarah, bitte.
SARAH: Boomerang! [Sally lacht]
SALLY: War das ein Boomerang?
SARAH: Das war ein Real Life Boomerang. Zum Wohl!
Ich muss sagen: Das ich das schönste Getränk, das ich je konsumiert habe.
Ich würde es, wenn ich gerade mein Handy dabei hätte,
in meiner Instagram Story laden.
SALLY: Ich dachte, sie sagt: Wenn ich einmal heirate,
möchte ich das als Hochzeitsgetränk.
SARAH: Oh ja, für den Sektempfang.
BEIDE: Alkoholfrei.
SALLY: Aber da kann man mit Sicherheit... Das habe ich schon einmal zubereitet
Ich habe einmal einen Lavendelsirup gemacht
und den kann man dann auch praktisch mit Sekt usw. aufgießen.
Gibt es auch auf meinem Kanal.
SARAH: So habe ich den noch nie getrunken.
SALLY: Oh, der ist gut.
SARAH: Ich rieche es schon.
SALLY: Die Deko ist zwar schön...
SARAH: Aber sie stört beim Trinken, so im Nasenloch. [Sally lacht]
SALLY: Man muss mit Röhrchen... Du hast da etwas in der Nase hängen. [Lacht]
SARAH: Ein Lavendelbusch.
Sehr lecker! Den Lavendel schmeckt man richtig gut heraus.
SALLY: Ja! Der Rosmarin müsste ein bisschen ziehen.
Also der in der Karaffe zieht jetzt schon ganz gut.
Also 3 Getränke für den Sommer zum mehr Trinken.
SARAH: Die erfrischend sind.
SALLY: Die erfrischend sind, gut schmecken, abwechslungsreich.
Schreibt mir gern einmal, welches dieser drei Getränke euer Favorit ist
und ob ihr noch weitere Getränkewünsche habt.
Wenn ihr wollt...
Aus meinem Team kam so ein bisschen der Wunsch nach Bubble Tea.
Ich finde es auch furchtbar,
aber vielleicht kriegen wir es ja mega lecker hin.
Okay. Sarah gehört anscheinend nicht zum Team. Alle so: Wuuh!
SARAH: Ich finde es zu süß und zu chemisch. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Aber das kriegen wir bestimmt besser hin.
SARAH: Ja, ich bin mir sicher, dass du es nicht so süß machst.
SALLY: Ja, wenn ihr es sehen möchtet, dann können wir das gerne...
Weil meine Kinder, also Samira, Ella und Murat, sind auch schon immer so:
Boah, Bubble Tea wollen wir haben und ich so:
Please no sugar!
SARAH: Wie? [Mit nachgemachter Stimme] Please no sugar!
SALLY: [Lacht] Also viel Spaß beim Nachmachen. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
SARAH: Wir stoßen noch einmal an.
SALLY: Wollen wir uns so rausdrehen? So synchron? Links, rechts? [Sarah bejaht]
Am Schluss noch und dann so raus. [Sarah stimmt zu]
[Musik]